season two of Brock Meyer premieres next
Wednesday that's April 25th at 10:00 on
IFC and you can watch season 1 right now
on Hulu always great to have you in Hank
how are you oh it's good to be here I'm
very good thank you dan thanks for
having me it's a pleasure to be I
finally I've only talked to you in New
York yeah the man cave this is the whole
man cave here yeah that's very
impressive yeah yes I did want to ask
you about Along Came Polly and now
you're obsessed I don't understand okay
you're so jacked in that movie yeah I
know
okay did you use performance-enhancing
obviously not no which no one believes
me anyway would you tell me if you used
peds I would I would be mildly
embarrassed to admit it if I did but I
would tell you because like they're
gonna throw me out of the Hall of Fame I
know Brock Meyers in the Baseball Hall I
know that like I get thrown out if I say
as an actor if I say I did that
no way there are guys in the Hall of
Fame abused peds so yeah there certainly
are in there yeah I should be in that
wing just because I'm suspected of it
but Hollywood you're allowed to use
people there's a guy in LA I said ask me
that exact question hey did you we on
steroids you know long camp all and I
said no I was doing what you say anyway
Hank you serious producers are oddly
obsessed with this won't take my shirt
off you don't do I'm gonna do this
interview pantsless I'll do that all
right be able to see what do you do what
I'll do it all right let's both get our
pants ready the interview yeah you go
first all right you fooled me that one
time I did that the 2018 Mercedes AMG
e-class a suite of innovative
technologies one of the most intelligent
cars on the road go to MBUSA dot-com
visit your local dealership to schedule
your test drive today you ever do music
never Yeah right
you have no musical talent my wife is
very musically gifted her father was a
concert level pianist was recruited by
the Philadelphia Philharmonic and my son
has inherited that ability nice but I am
completely devoid of talent first
concert that Hank Azaria went to was
1976 Madison Square Garden Jethro Tull
Oh
sitting on a park bench yeah watching
little girls with bad intention
yeah hey Aqualung I'll be a good one for
Jim brag man I know Kid Rock Meyer
doesn't sing though
well no black man will sing not as much
Rock Meyer sing take me out and does he
do seventh-inning stretch yes he did in
fact it was documented in the in the doc
in the mini documentary that you helped
us with that he did alternate lyrics
that's one of the things that got him in
trouble that's yeah with his ex-wife yes
he was upset about his ex-wives
curricular exploits and I think that he
used a bad word take me out to the
ballgame table buy me some peanuts and
cracker jack my wife is a mmm yeah my
wife is a bad word that's how he where
he went into that's how he performed it
that day and that's part of what got him
thrown out of baseball
what do you sit about Brock Meyer that
we like well oh you want us to like well
he look in the I'm confused as to where
their answer is Brock Meyer no give it
to me Hank I think that like in the
tradition of deciding for me because
it's guy get very confused okay in the
tradition of like Forrest Gump and other
characters and like Sex Lies and
videotape he will just say the truth you
know whether it's because he's in a
blackout drunk or just because you can
get away with really saying anything you
want as long as you say it this way and
give the count right afterwards so
that's kind of fun about him and he's
pretty insightful and and he's funny and
witty but also one of the it lends
itself to observational humor when
you're talking like this because all
you're doing is describing everything
you're seeing that's his job but you're
the opposite of Vin Scully I would say
he is well they share some I mean VIN by
the end whatever litical rants you know
and then the count came I always loved
that that no matter what you're talking
about it always has to come back to
here's the two - exactly that's what's
hilarious about one of the things it's
hilarious you jump at anything well you
know that came from like
growing up I'm a Mets guy but listening
to phil rizzuto growing up and he there
was more right especially in a game that
wasn't closed yeah you get long
descriptions of the Italian meal he had
that night that was most of the game oh
man they do a sausage and peppers over
there at tutorials you can't believe it
and Sonny comes out there with the red
wine on a checkered tablecloth as
Chambliss looks at a break I mean it's
like what are you talking about man
Rizzuto was just had so many non
sequiturs you know that Phil would be
like you know it's the balloon that's
that it's tethered but it gets so far
away yes that you have to bring over the
kite and then you have to bring it back
that's exactly what I mean so I became
obsessed with how far can you actually
go with that which led to like Brock
Meyer cursing and describing sex acts
and then coming back to Johnson looking
outside one of those but do you have you
thought about like John sterling home
run calls well well brockmore has many
ridiculous home run calls that almost
seem tame community John sterling yes
yes are you thinking about kind of
amping those up just to top stories
could you have Brock Meyer have sort of
a feud with the Yankee announcer like
John sterling that you're he's sort of
invading in your territory achma is
currently in several of you well Jill
bug on your Oh Bucky can't stay in but
who can pardon me but I I almost threw
up in my mouth just mentioned just
talking about enema and of course
Musburger brent musburger is a punk a
thieving lying Punk and Brock Maher
hates them and and you know and rightly
so let's face it
so yeah let's start one with sterling
yeah Brock Meyer had there's a lot of a
lot of home run calls at Brock my how to
reject over the years okay like some
that weren't great you know he like
plays on the word gone that ball is gone
you know somebody inject me with
penicillin because that ball is
gonorrhea never caught on why not I
don't know
I'm surprised that ball is the female
leader the running man call it maria
conchita a gun
that one never caught that's a little
deep yeah it's a deep cut yeah here's a
deeper cut all know somebody called that
ball a failed contestant on the old
version of American Idol because that
one is gone Stanton marilla's see that
no it's not nobody understand Dennis
Miller even said what what are you
talking about like I don't get it babe
you're going too deep my Dennis Miller
sounds like Sammy Davis for some it did
and you had the delivery I'm excited I
got problems there do you do impressions
though of just regular people I know
that you do voices on Simpsons but who
are the go-to many of those are just
imitations of red like people I grew up
with or teachers or relatives or
whatever yes you know and I will mimic
gal I mimicked anything I heard any
person in DeNiro then he was mostly a
facial fresh you know I don't do a great
thing your own yeah can't have it okay
at the house commiserating can't do it
you do it who do you really like doing
I get addicted to do well Brock Meyer
was one of those that wouldn't get out
of my head I did so many years just I
called it the generic baseball guy that
if I you know I start doing
Woody Allen aye well Donna you know the
old Woody Allen you know when we all
liked never done one in front of
somebody that you're doing I'm so
terrified of that no I hate that when
they say oh he does a great impression
you should probably bring out Woody
Allen here bring out Robert I don't know
if De Niro would I just work with De
Niro last year I would have never you
know first of all it's not that good as
you just saw my DeNiro and do you call
him Bobby what are you allowed to call
mom Bob because that's what he's called
he does Bob I'd you know in my brain
it's mr. DeNiro but it comes out Bob
just to be polite and friendly nervous
yeah very nervous to be around you know
I've I don't ever get used to that like
in the bird cage you guys are obsessed
with where I did not use any
performance-enhancing drugs
uh you know gene Hackman Robin Williams
you know I was kind of freaking my Mike
Nichols so that I never get over that
Hackman is not acting anymore right
I guess not I don't think no I think
he's retired but I mean he had I go back
to the French Connection with him you
know what he did in Hoosiers and yes you
forget how great I was reading up on the
Dan Nets Pauli's Hoosiers your favorite
absolutely yeah mine too yeah I think
it's hands-down the best sports movie
ever you did some homework I was looking
I was on the website what are you doing
and learning about the dad ad oh I don't
it's a long drive from the city oh my
I'm learning about the dance as well so
what kind of plot twists and turns do we
have season two rock my hair Brack my
very good well if you remember if recall
season one available on Hulu as you
mentioned Hulu is fun to say his
Brockman
it sounds like hello yeah his way of
saying hey the decent homerun call in
itself you know and that ball is not
Netflix Amazon a Maga yeah all right so
what kind of Plenty range do we have he
end of season one he goes off to
triple-a to call a game for the New
Orleans crawdaddies which in our world
is in the Atlanta farm system with hopes
of Joe Buck has taken pity on him and
made an entree into the Atlanta
organization but they got to make sure
Brock Myers gonna be ok and actually
show up to the game sober and they need
him to call some triple-a here for a
while and then and he's been there for
very long there's kind of a legendary
Vin Scully like broadcaster in Atlanta
that is they thought would step down but
isn't and Brock Myers getting very
impatient and without his lady love
Amanda Peet who is in season two but
they're separated and in New Orleans
which is kind of the right place for an
alcoholic to really go pro he may not be
in the major leagues but his alcoholism
really hits a second
there how many broadcasters do you think
make up Brock Meyer the jacket is
Lindsay Nelson and those guys like the
late great Craig Sager who young Walt
Frazier's likes to wear flamboyant
outfits the voice is kind of a generic
conglomeration of what I remember it's
just the average guy calling a game we
to me you still here this guy Saturday
afternoons and your average NCAA
broadcast you'll still get this guy who
kind of gives you to you lag loose and I
don't know who he is or who they are but
they give you a college games right but
Bob Murphy who did the medal Bob Murphy
is a little he's Brock Meyer after he
smoked about I never there was a game
where the Mets beat the Phillies and I
think was Phillies he was just fed up
that the Mets allowed the Phillies to
come back and they win the damn game he
says the damn gas and they win it won
the damn game I think he was just so
upset that it took so long who knows he
may have had dinner reservation back
then it was was a Rheingold yeah yeah he
had a few you could tell that there were
some rheingold's involved in the broad
gasps any other cameo so you got Joe
Buck who you hate hey Joe yeah uh
actually loved your buddy but hate robot
rock my hates in my love okay this is
the dichotomy No season two we don't
have any actual broadcasting pros
involved because okay so just a story
went a different way I'm correct when I
say oh no Joe actually does come back in
for kind of a brief but memorable
section yeah buck does come back in yes
polling you had a question for Hank
who's here we did some research on Hank
as well and we just watch sometimes we
can't confirm whether you've been in a
movie or not were you do you have a
cameo or a small role in pretty woman
yes
what was your role cuz we can't fight we
saw a very like the first five minutes
of the movie I play a cop who is
questioning somebody on this you know
Julia Roberts the very opening credits
like another prostitute has been killed
in
being pulled out of a dumpster and it
freaks her out and I'm a cop questioning
like a guy on the street do you remember
what that was like yeah because then
that's one of your first roles I'm
guessing yeah I think there's a first
part in a movie okay so you don't know
Julia Roberts is I knew who she was I
mean but she was not Julia Roberts know
that he made her a huge star but by
actor standards she was already huge
when she did mystic pizza exactly yeah
Richard Gere was he was big enough yeah
he was the name but you know you get
cast in that movie you have any idea
it's gonna be good
not only any idea was me good it was
like Garry Marshalls first big movie as
well I think so you didn't think that
necessarily he was gonna you know he had
brought us happy days and surely in all
kinds of television but but I
the only other job I had gotten I got
cut out and I have a TV show and I told
people I was good and then there were
like great job man see half my face for
half a second so I didn't tell anybody
that I had a few lines in this movie and
by the time it came out I had forgotten
that I didn't tell anyone and I got all
these calls like what'd you tell a
person you're in a movie I'm like oh I
forgot I kept that a secret were you up
for the Michael Scott rule in the office
no I heard you guys try I was like
getting ready to leave the other day and
I had your show on as I do
and here you guys talking about me I'm
like no that I don't know where you got
that not even close
you were never you didn't audition
didn't audition well I auditioned twice
to be on frell of Joey Matt LeBlanc role
I auditioned and then they said no and
then I the only time I've ever bowled my
way back a few days later
do you hate Joey no I love Matt LeBlanc
but when you watch Joey do you go that
could have been me yeah no because he
was so much better than I ever could
have been they made the right decision
and I ended up you know doing a
recurring part that was better for me on
that show so did you date anybody from
friends it's a great question no Matthew
Matthew Perry he was my best friend
we came up together I met Matthew we did
our first I I did my first TV job with
him a pilot
and like Lisa Kudrow seems like that
would be in your wheelhouse
I had a period of time where I was
always kissing her in one project or
other friends or another movie we did
together but no she was already highly
romantically spoken for and I was at the
time with Helen Hunt we were together
okay so do you rehearse kissing on
friends
that's no you that's a funny actor thing
where like you have to rehearse kissing
or vaccines whatever yeah generally you
sort of say and this is the part where
we're kissed and we'll do that on the
day and not really rehearse that now
because that's weird
like if you're rehearsing a kiss and
you're alone together what's the
difference between that and just making
out yeah agree if there's not a camera
there or somebody else there well I had
a role in Santa movie blended where I
have to kiss the star of the Goldbergs
Wendy Cove II yes she's my very talented
very yes but it wasn't in the script so
we're going through our read-through
right at the baseball field and then
Sandler goes Danny you should kiss her
and I would I didn't know how to act and
then she didn't she didn't do anything
my daughter was there or were they
rolling was this like no we're
rehearsing or just so he wanted me and
my daughter is watching and she's so
samurai I thought was punking me I
didn't think it was going to be in the
movie was he no okay so you actually
ended up did yeah okay and then I don't
know how to kiss somebody when I'm
acting no one does you just kind of roll
with it and no I gave tongue that's
methods actors don't do that far with
the whole thing well Bobby told me De
Niro told me that that's what you do the
neuro told Janice Bonnie did Wow you
know I think he might have been punking
you by the way you and Pacino have to do
it Cher birthday we did something I know
that yeah and and Joe Buck you well yeah
Renee Zellweger Ella Fitzgerald
I know Mall all the all the April 25th
birthday I give me a little Brock Meyer
before we wrap things so
do you wanna what about it I uh let's
talk about my Hall of Fame how about hi
I know
by the way Brock Meyer the sport code
yes is the microphone in the whole
microphone and the sport coat that's
pretty cool
hey that's by the way I jump it out of
character okay that's actually true it
really is in the Hall of Fame back to
Brock Meyer it's a tremolo is it
emotional though yes like I'm being
honest that you're a sports fan you grew
up a Mets are you asking me yes damn it
I rock Myers not here no one talked to
my little friend okay everyone okay hi
okay Stuart that had to be pretty
emotional I'm go pretty cool that you
got your gear you're immortalized it
freaked me out actually so much so that
I was like you know I actually tried to
have the Isaac I don't think I deserve
this you know let's literally think
about this guys because or maybe Brock
Meyer should be a little bit more of a
cultural phenomenon at least yeah and
grow our audience before we have this
honor but they really wanted to do it so
I was like well Who am I to say no to
that I'd have Brock Myers send us to
break by the way season 2 of Brock Meyer
premieres next Wednesday that'll be a
10:00 Eastern on IFC and make sure you
check out season 1 it's available on
blue very excited about the Hall of Fame
dan Patrick you know it's something I
dreamed of my whole life so much so that
I once I put a plaque of my
accomplishments up in a handicapped
toilet stall on the second floor of the
Hall of Fame just to get in there and
obviously this actual honor means more
to me but I'm still I'm not taking down
the toilet great to see you Hank thanks
for joining us for having me and once
again he did not use
performance-enhancing drugs for any of
his movie roles but he may have made out
with either Matthew Perry or Lisa Kudrow
or not we're not quite sure that was
drug-induced form or Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
you